this vlog with a $50,000 camera we're
vlogging I have to go undercover and
infiltrate the Eurobeat community can I
focus right like we're like literally
about to hit export on the video and
there's still two shots we haven't
filmed everyone's at NAB you think you
guys wanted us to shoot a Sam and Nico
video Danny do we have any cameras ready
um no actually
apparently using my iPhone I don't
really feel like walking around like
this yeah I don't really know what they
want us to vlog either senses literally
just us to hear and we're not doing
anything yeah I guess we can go get
lunch or something are you just gonna
vlog on that I don't know man
I read yeah this vlog with a $50,000
camera I've seen comments out there like
why why don't you guys ever use the red
to vlog that's a good point why don't we
ever use this camera
alright let's power this baby imma start
vlogging a lot of vloggers like the ATD
because they have like that screen that
twists out well guess what this sucker
right here for 50k I mean you got a much
bigger display so hopefully the rest of
the vlog will be shot on this let me
just try to get my focus right yeah how
hot is it today it feels like 90 degrees
apparently when it gets like warm the
camera this fan start spinning really
fast
that's probably not great for noise to
do it
says we're vlogging
okay look I guess this is fine somewhere
I'll see you all right sorry okay sorry
well without strike two yeah yeah it's
kind of hard to tell if it focuses good
whatever it's 8k Danny
[Music]
[Applause]
I feel like that's kind of vlog
discrimination like we could have walked
in there with like a tiny little camera
and they wouldn't said it they didn't
say anything about your phone yeah
when I say
in conclusion even though the red is
really good camera the Reds got a great
sensor 8k really great features it's
probably the worst vlog camera on the
planet because no one will let you vlog
with it it's it intimidates everyone
that sees it everyone who looks at it
sort of just gives it like a weird side
I like I don't want to be on beyond the
camera
yeah I don't think people like this
[Music]
yeah it looks good it's dude the story's
amazing look how many VFX shots taro -
so far every single one on this top is
the VFX shot there's small gaps where
there's no VFX it's Friday you got three
days left everything's going well I've
been doing VFX all week it's great but
the music that's the hardest part it's
really hard to find people making
Eurobeat in the year 2018 if I'm not
mistaken your beats from like like 2004
because there's no royalty-free Eurobeat
music up there it's like all either 10
years old or there's like one or two
people making it there's a there's a
euro beat monopoly happening right now I
have to go undercover and infiltrate the
Eurobeat community to get a song by
Monday I so far I've been spamming two
guys who run a euro beef let record
label in Japan and I don't think they
speak English so I'm using Google
Translate to just like write really
basic things like we want your music and
we will license you our music we can't
money a little bit of money they haven't
been responding go watch anime
self-driving cars on corridor right now
just stop what you're doing with this
video and go watch it right now because
we're spoilers ahead
we've spent we spent months of this
spent more time on this video we have
anything on any other video on the
channel and Ren is mouse skeleton you
don't care these a skeleton and don't
watch it but if you feel bad for him in
a skeletonized form then pay honor to
his memory and go watch anime
self-driving cars he's ok he's right
there this videos been a little bit
stressful this is the East year amount
of VFX shots and it's like it's because
there's a lot of VFX shots and there's a
pretty good plan for about half of them
and the other ones there's it's just
like there's no plan every day i bang
out about 12 to 15 VFX shots for it and
i think there's about 100
it's because of the incredible pace that
we're doing the VFX a lot of things are
slipping between the cracks so what
we've done is decided all right we can
get all the shots rendered up this week
and then of the Monday the day before
your release that will go through find
the the biggest perpetrators the ones
that have glitches or just something
some sloppy work in them clean them up
just a little bit and because of the
sheer volume of the effect shots me out
it's like yeah the true conception of
this video is like two years ago two
years ago three years ago I was thinking
okay self-driving cars are becoming a
thing let's let's riff on that it's an
awkward race of two cars driving with
the passengers just oblivious since that
idea came up we had made two anime
videos Niko really liked the idea so we
decided to write up like a script for
this video the idea of this and it was
like I was like holy cow I did I never
imagined making it an anime video but
the material it was good and the only
thing stopping us was having a budget so
we got a little budget to do it
boom two years later but yeah I know
we've actually been actually working on
it for about like three months no it's
almost me so I've lost all track of time
so there's a crapload of the effects
shots and I think when you watch the
whole video it becomes very cohesion and
I'm thinking about like alright well how
could I maybe organize to plan this a
little bit better leaving for a month or
so in the middle of the project isn't
the best way to do it but like here's
the dilemma so we have like this super
crazy visual project I think will
release and some people see it going
holy crap that's the same all these
shots are crazy and like it all flows
I'm like wow it looks like these guys
making it our geniuses and have this
plan all along it's like no if you ask
me what this video is gonna look like
before you started filming it I would
have had no idea when when they would
have said oh that idea for the random
blueprint shot in it or the intermission
it's like no no I didn't plan that stuff
before we filmed it and I didn't even
find it after week I'm gonna find it
like in the middle of doing the effects
and editing it's like it's this wiggle
room and the freedom to evolve the idea
as you're working on it all out this
video to flourish I guess the challenge
here is like we do want to do bigger
projects get bigger budgets to work on
make this but even even crazier but then
how how do you deal with the fact that
when you start getting with more budgets
and more time and all this stuff how do
you still get this level of quality when
you have all those strings that end up
getting attached to bigger budget that
makes s this is the thing
because after doing all these larger
projects like the YouTube bread series
and echo 90 series the set for lifeline
I would say it's like the most
creatively limiting set I've ever been
on because there's so many boundaries
like so how do I take this process and
apply it to a even larger project
because so far my experience with larger
projects has been frankly creatively
limiting I get my main move maybe that's
just it though
maybe you can't make this kind of stuff
so that's how we're gonna stroke that's
why we're structuring that differently
we're not going to be running it like
we've run the set ever extra extra time
more time than a normal film shoot but
at the expense of a smaller crew I
opened this up I didn't know what it was
I thought some crazy fan said this some
pizza in a bag and it turns out some
crazy fan dissipates in a bag and his
name is Harley Morenstein co-founder of
Epic Meal Time
I guess what they've gone and done is
what pizza and a bag super snack time is
gonna be available in Walmart almost at
all Walmart's a man's making big moves
I'm gonna try this right now here's the
thing and this isn't it ain't
immigration or anything but you might
think that when your friends make a
weird snack thing that you had to like
I'd say it's good and stuff but this
one's actually legitimately pretty good
it's basically Pizza jerky you like to
try some pepperoni
is this like oh my god it works it works
it does it's like if you took a combo
bagged pepperoni and ate them at the
same time I just filling that's pretty
good just straight-up tastes like pizza
it's like if here goes enough he's
literally a piece I mean literally a
piece of salami what's sauce all over
honey some kind of his pizza
hey did it hardly steal my slogan you're
welcome that's been my slogan on Sam and
Nico for like a year now dude when every
time I do a brand integration and I give
people an offer code to get something
for cheaper than what it costs I go
you're welcome
I don't think I've ever heard
Arlie thanks for the pizza in a bag
we'll see you in court
you're welcome I'm finna back pepperoni
pizza in my pocket
Carly thanks for feeding my boys yeah
thanks thanks Harley you're welcome the
enemy video is finally out please go
check it out see love and time and
energy and labor that went into this
masterpiece I'm pretty proud of it I
think it I think he's pretty cool no
it's one of a kind video check it out
card floating around on the screen right
now those magic buttons ooze for
floating around over there do you see
that am i seeking that you see that
little button yes I got the music I just
slid into these like freaking Japanese
Eurobeat guy dams I got permission to
use their music and they're really
excited to have it in this video I think
putting the song and the video clip
together where it's going to use paid
off lots of exclamation marks you know
like I can tell through the translated
Japanese to English it's a plus this
little light yeah did that it's the same
one you're using this little light oh my
god I've been using the crap out of
these on this anime shoot so far because
they're perfect for car interiors yeah
isn't this tiny little thing you can go
stick it wherever you want we release
the anime video tomorrow and there have
been two shots in the video that we have
left on the film's all the way until
just now like we're like literally about
to hit export on the video and there's
still two shots we haven't filmed so
we're gonna film them really quick with
the janky assets of set up the loading
dock is blocked it's a car interior shot
we need to control the lighting
button blankets on a car are you ready
to hop in the oven I love being an oven
so we're like thinking to get these
shots these are two shots we need inside
a car
nighttime in controlled lighting rather
than get into the loading docks since
its blocked right now by some buttheads
we are just blacking out my car we're
gonna throw one single m9 light in there
and film two shots what are the shots
well it's a self-driving car race and in
self-driving cars you don't need to use
your hands to hurt filming to insert
shots of people fidgeting and playing
around with their hands in the middle of
this intense race I think it's kind of
the source of the comedy for the entire
video really important I don't know why
we filmed it earlier rain just
disappeared
oh it's a one wheel thing you see when
you're a one wheeler you see another one
wheel as like it's instant attraction
wheels attract all right each wheel he
needs another wheel that's that's the
foundation of most physics and driving
so in one wheel sees another there's
instant attracts are you talking about
how they had no choice but to leave I
apologize it wasn't Mike no you know
it's like deep biological the a seats
all dank it's like a swamp I haven't
cleaned my car out for like five months
no I haven't cleaned my car since I went
to see the Eclipse unless August so
that's
so many months we have our Funzone we
need for that shot yo be like racer Z
and go watch this video it's up right
now we're all really proud of it we put
a lot of work and effort
oh god I'm running over blankets check
it out right now look in the description
[Music]